hello my name is Alicia and what I would
like to know is you think time Israel
for example sometimes an hour can still
very short and sometimes it can feel
very long depending on your perception
so then is time subjective if it's a
measurement of something what is it a
measurement of I'd really like to know
your thoughts about time Thank You
Alicia that is fantastic
notice that in English we don't have any
other word for time except time it's
unique is it's this wild fourth
dimension in nature this is one
dimension this is one dimension this is
one dimension then time is the fourth
dimension and we call it the fourth
dimension
not just in theoretical physics but in
engineering and I worked on four
dimensional auto pilots so you tell
where you want to go and what altitude
it is above sea level and then when you
want to get there
but you can't get there at any time we
have a whole bunch other words we have
appointments we have morning afternoon
evening noontime nighttime we have a
whole bunch of words describing periods
of time but when it comes to actual time
we just have this one word it's a
strange and surprising thing so along
this line in my opinion which as you
know is correct I'm kidding
in my opinion time is both subjective
and and objective what we do in science
and engineering and in life astronomy is
measure time as carefully as we can
because it's so important to our
everyday world you go to plant crops you
want to know when to plant them you want
to know when to harvest them if you want
to have a global positioning system that
enables you to determine which side of
the street you're on from your phone you
need to take into account both the
traditional passage of time that you
might be familiar with watching a clock
here on the Earth's surface
and the passage of time as it's affected
by the speed of the spacecraft and the
passage of time as it's affected by the
gravity of the earth itself both special
and general relativity is astonishing we
work very hard to measure time with all
sorts of extraordinary clocks but there
is no question with our brains which are
wet chemical computers we lose track of
time we don't know if it feels if it
sometimes it feels short sometimes it
feels long and it's just the nature I
think of being constrained by measuring
time with our brains this is why we
build instruments to measure time
outside of ourselves externally but it
is a great question and then the whole
idea of science really started with this
thing people used to call natural
philosophy and when you throw in the
word philosophy for me you start asking
this question like can you know anything
let alone what time it is or how long
it's been sand something happened or
whether or not or when something will
happen in the future or whether or not
it will happen at all
these are philosophical questions and I
feel that you can get yourself pretty
spun up and in saying to yourself
there's no way to know anything you can
philosophically you can't know anything
on the other hand it seems to me we can
know a great deal about nature and that
includes time and its passage one last
thought Alicia when I think about my
grandfather he had no idea no
understanding of relativity for not
because he was a bad person because no
one had discovered it yet and so I just
wonder what else it is about the nature
of time or the nature of what physicists
astrophysicists like to call space-time
or the where you talk about these four
dimensions at once X Y Z and T I cannot
help but wonder there is something else
undiscovered about time and perhaps you
and I will be alive not much more time
will have passed before this discovery
is made carry on
excellent question thank you
[Music]